I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an environment. goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way, because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's
我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家CAM服务机构担任助理医师。我购买并阅读了玛丽安的《临床心理学家集体》一书，作为我申请临床心理学培训时的陪伴。事实证明，它确实是一个很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它提供了一个沉浸在他人故事中的机会。它及时提醒我们，不要太执着于某个目标，而要珍惜并享受我们一路走来所从事的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都有意义。它还让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对我这样一个走过弯路、并非典型职业路径的人来说非常重要。
had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though. because once you've started reading, it's tough to put it down. What if the thing you've been searching for your whole life isn't happiness, not success, not confidence, not motivation? What if it's safety? Because when humans feel truly safe, something remarkable happens. We learn, we connect, we create and we grow.
我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过，请做好准备，暂时搁置晚上的任务，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。如果说你一生都在寻找的不是幸福、不是成功、不是自信、也不是动力，那会是什么呢？如果那是安全感呢？因为当人类感到真正安全时，非凡的事情就会发生。我们学习、我们连接、我们创造、我们成长。
And today I'm going to explore the psychology of feeling safe. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Welcome to Inner Work. In the main episode of psychology, actually, I was talking with Dr. Mia Hobbes and Dr. Paula Redmond about knitting. And one of the things that came up was the idea of safety, really, and how it seemed to give them those moments of deep exhale to be knitting and engaged in that in a way which just lights them up and helps them to relax. in a way that nothing else seems to do. And this idea of safety and the psychology of safety is one that I keep coming back to and tripping over lately.
今天，我将探讨安全感的心理学。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。欢迎来到《内在工作》。在《心理学，实际上》的主节目中，我曾与米娅·霍布斯博士和保拉·雷德蒙德博士谈论过编织。其中提到的一个点是关于安全感的概念，以及编织如何让他们获得那种深呼吸的时刻，让他们沉浸其中，以一种点亮他们并帮助他们放松的方式，这是其他任何事情都无法做到的。这种安全感和安全心理学的概念是我最近不断回味和思考的问题。
I'd love to know, how would you know if you felt safe? When did you last feel safe? How would you know what that would look like? So let's take a little look at what safety is. I think firstly it might be helpful to look at it being an absence of something. of something. So that's no danger, no threat, no risk. And often when I'm with people, and we kind of do achieve that sense of safety, you do notice those deep exhale moments. And it's a really physiological shift when you have that. I hope you are regularly
我很想知道，你怎么知道自己是否有安全感？你上次感到安全是什么时候？你怎么知道那会是什么样子？让我们来看看什么是安全感。我认为首先从它的缺失角度来看可能会有帮助。也就是没有危险、没有威胁、没有风险。通常当我与人们在一起时，如果我们达到了那种安全感，你确实会注意到那些深呼吸的时刻。当你拥有这种感觉时，这是一种真正的生理转变。我希望你经常
experiencing moments of safety, if not, you know, period of and chunks of feeling safe and loved and contained. But what I know is that that is not the case for lots of people. Lots of people because of the way they've been raised or because of the relationships they found themselves in as a result of friendships or intimate partner relationships will be constantly kind of scanning for criticism, constantly on edge and expecting things to be, you know,
体验到安全感的时刻，如果不是的话，你知道，那些感到安全、被爱和被包容的时期和片段。但我知道，对于许多人来说并非如此。许多人因为他们的成长方式，或者因为他们在友谊或亲密伴侣关系中发现自己所处的关系，会不断地扫描批评，不断地处于边缘，并期待事情会，你知道，
problematic and chaotic soon. And so sometimes even when somebody's feeling safe, that can feel really threatening in itself because their whole kind of body, mind and soul, if you like, is constantly scanning for that threat and thinking it's all going to go to pot any minute now. So, you know, abort, abort, get safe, get safe. Because actually their nervous system has been raised and schooled on chaos and unpredictability. So when things feel consistent and calm and kind of like plodding along or like your needs are being met, that can feel threatening in itself. And as a result, there might be some kind of self-sabotage behaviour, so ending a relationship or, you know, doing something a little bit more chaotic or or finding fault in situations where there might not actually be any fault. and, you know, just kind of blowing up our lives a little bit.
很快就会变得有问题和混乱。因此，有时即使当某人感到安全时，这本身也可能让人感到非常威胁，因为他们的整个身心，如果可以这样说的话，都在不断地扫描那种威胁，并认为随时都会崩溃。所以，你知道，中止，中止，寻求安全，寻求安全。因为实际上他们的神经系统是在混乱和不可预测的环境中成长和受教的。所以当事情感觉一致、平静、按部就班，或者你的需求得到满足时，这本身就可能让人感到威胁。结果，可能会出现某种自我破坏行为，比如结束一段关系，或者，你知道，做一些更混乱的事情，或者在实际上可能没有过错的情况下在情况中找茬，而且，你知道，只是把我们的生活搞得一团糟。
So I would invite you, if you're watching this, to reflect on what behaviours crop up for you when you feel safe. Are they always adaptive, which would be leaning in, taking those breaths, enjoying those moments, or do they sometimes look a little bit different? What happens when we're not feeling safe is that we will likely strive all the harder. We might overwork, we might outperform people or want to, we might mask our true feelings, we might push people away, we might people please, or we might just generally feel like we are burning out or that we're not truly being seen for who we are. None of that feels very gratifying.
所以，如果你正在看这个视频，我想邀请你反思一下当你感到安全时会出现什么样的行为。它们总是适应性的吗，比如倾听、深呼吸、享受那些时刻，还是有时看起来有点不同？当我们没有安全感时，我们很可能会更加努力地奋斗。我们可能会过度工作，我们可能会表现得比别人好或者想要那样，我们可能会掩盖真实的感受，我们可能会推开别人，我们可能会讨好别人，或者我们可能只是普遍感到精疲力竭，或者觉得我们没有被真正地看到。这些都让人感觉不到满足。
And, you know, none of it is sustainable in the medium to long term. People find safety in a variety of ways. So it might be that, you know, like Mia, like Paula, you're finding it in knitting or something crafty. When I haven't got a broken hand, I like a little bit of calligraphy every now and then. I like swimming. I like walking. I love cuddles with my children. My youngest one is especially snugly. And, you know, as I'm recording this, he's about to turn 10.
而且，你知道，从中期到长期来看，这些都是不可持续的。人们通过各种方式寻找安全感。所以可能是，你知道，像米娅，像保拉，你在编织或某种手工艺中找到它。当我的手没有受伤时，我偶尔喜欢练习书法。我喜欢游泳。我喜欢散步。我喜欢和我的孩子们拥抱。我最小的孩子特别喜欢依偎。而且，你知道，当我录制这段音频时，他快要10岁了。
And he promises me he will always remain snugly. But, you know, probably he won't. I'm going to need to look to get my snuggles in elsewhere, so I will drop a memo to the husband that more hugs are going to be required. Thank you for being here for Inner Work. I would love any feedback you have. This is a pretty new show, so I would love to know that it's hitting the spot. The next episode of Inner Work will be available wherever you get your podcast and on YouTube from 8pm UK time. And then Psychology Actually, as you might know already, is available on Saturdays from 10am on YouTube and whatever you get your podcast from 6am on Monday. Take care.
他向我保证他会一直喜欢依偎。但是，你知道，他可能不会。我需要寻找其他地方来获得拥抱，所以我会在备忘录里提醒丈夫，以后需要更多的拥抱。感谢你来到《内在工作》。我很乐意收到你的任何反馈。这是一个相当新的节目，所以我很想知道它是否触动了你的心弦。《内在工作》的下一集将从英国时间晚上8点开始，在你获取播客的任何地方以及YouTube上提供。然后《心理学，实际上》，正如你可能已经知道的那样，在周六上午10点在YouTube上提供，并在周一上午6点在你获取播客的任何地方提供。保重。
Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book of the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get on to the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，以帮助自己为第一轮博士申请做准备，我很高兴我买了它。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，它让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多反思。它还有助于将事情放在正确的角度，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。然而，我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣是每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心。每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力，真是一种享受。我几乎不想读到结尾。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。